so we Christian conservatives are very
often accused of trying to impose our
religion on others of trying to push our
religion no matter what the topic is no
matter what we're talking about it
always comes back to that
our opponent is always going to accuse
us in the end of you're trying to push
your religion on me and this will even
happen when they're the first ones to
bring up religion so I don't know how
many times I've had a conversation like
this where I'm I'm talking often to a
liberal and they'll say well you know
the Bible and Jesus agree with me on
this topic I mean Jesus said himself
that he agrees with me on whatever topic
we're talking about and then I'll say
well no he doesn't and in fact here are
a couple verses that prove and then
he'll say stop pushing your religion on
me why do you bring up religion all the
time I didn't you did
so there's this weird thing that
liberals do well they're they they will
try to use their first tactic is to try
to use my religion against me and when
that doesn't work then they'll claim
that religion has nothing to do with it
we should be talking about religion so
this is this is the way it usually goes
this is especially the case when it
comes to the topic of abortion and now
roe v wade which has been the subject of
conversation obviously for the last
couple weeks and we were again as
conservatives we were once again accused
of this on of all places Fox News
yesterday when pro-abortion pundit Tommy
Lehren took to the airwaves to declare
on Fox News that overturning roe v wade
would be religious judicial activism and
thus unconstitutional she says
and this I mean this is a Nancy Pelosi
level talking point the idea that it is
unconstitutional and religious activism
to overturn roe v wade is a Nancy Pelosi
level talking point M right when I say
Nancy Pelosi level I mean that it is
radically progressive and also it is
extremely lazy and incredibly stupid
and I don't know how else to put it just
lazy and stupid talking point
and yet this one of the most radical one
of the laziest one of the stupidest
leftist talking point is coming out of
the mouth of an alleged spokeswoman for
conservatism
like someone that people turn to for
insights into conservatism I mean it's
it's it's mind-boggling
but I think Tommy did us a favor by
bringing this up because it gives us the
opportunity to discuss why this claim of
pushing religion by opposing the murder
of infants is false and so I want to
take advantage of that opportunity and
there are a few points to make here so
first of all let's some you you know
that roe v wade and abortion are kind of
two separate topics they in that if you
re if you are a rational thinking person
and you understand how the government
works and you understand how the
Constitution works or is supposed to
work and you understand how the Supreme
Court works or is supposed to work then
you should be opposed to roe v wade on
that basis alone even if you think
abortion is the greatest thing in the
world if you claim to be a
constitutionalist which Tommy does
then you should definitely be opposed to
roe v-- wade on constitutional grounds
even if you don't oppose it on moral
grounds or on any other ground it is not
judicial activism much less is it
religious judicial activism to overturn
previous examples of judicial activism
that's something the court should do roe
v wade itself was judicial activism so
the main legal argument against Roe is
not that abortion is a terrible thing
and it kills a person although that is a
legal argument against it and I think a
pretty good one but that's not them
actually the primary legal argument the
primary legal argument against Roe is
that Roe itself was in incorrect legal
decision
the Supreme Court this is what happened
in roe v-- wade the Supreme Court found
in the Constitution a right to abortion
even though abortion is never mentioned
anywhere in the dot in the document
there's no there's no mention of
abortion in in the Constitution nor did
any of the framers even hint that they
had abortion anywhere in their minds
when they wrote the document
but of course the court recognized this
obstacle because it had to and so it
this is what it did it inferred a right
to abortion from the right to privacy
found in the 14th amendment the only
problem of course is that the 14th
amendment doesn't say anything about a
right to privacy there is no right to
privacy the phrase right to privacy
doesn't appear anywhere in the bill of
rights at all the phrase right to
privacy is a phrase used by previous
courts so they use the precedent of
previous courts to infer it in amendment
Witter didn't exist and where even if
we're the right to privacy did exist in
that amendment it still wouldn't have
anything to do it all with abortion
um
so again the court founded its right to
abortion which is not enumerated on
another right which is not enumerated
and which even if it were enumerated
would have would not apply at all to
abortion
but the case is even more absurd than
that because let's look at the 14th
amendment section 1 of the 14th
amendment which is where this right to
abortion came from
especially this part of it
nor shall any state deprive any person
of life liberty or property without due
process of law nor deny to any person
within its jurisdiction the equal
protection of the laws
so
thing in there about privacy
there's nothing in there about abortion
but
again as just a rational person if you
were to not you know not knowing
anything about roe v wade or even
anything about the constitution if you
were to read that phrase
and then someone were to ask you how
does that apply it to abortion what's
the first thing you would say you would
say well clearly this is a law against
abortion because you can't deprive any
person of light without due process of
law and also equal protection under the
law so abortion obviously deprives a
human being of a life that's a
biological fact you know if you have a
living human organism which is now not
living anymore because of abortion and
there's no due process of law also these
unborn humans are by definition not
treated equally they have no perd forget
about equal protection they have zero
protection under the law
so that's the only way a sane person
could possibly apply that Clause to
abortion but instead the court found
found you can't deprive any person of
life liberty or property without due
process of law as a as a as a
codification of our right to kill people
I mean what
but you know this apparently some
conservatives find that to be completely
completely rational this is judicial
activism judicial activism is when the
court realizes that a particular thing
is not in the Constitution so at issues
a ruling pretending that that thing is
in the Constitution because it the court
believes that it should be in the
Constitution
that's what judicial activism is and
that's what the Court did in roe v wade
without saying it directly although they
almost said it directly they their point
was well yeah of course the Constitution
doesn't protect abortion but it should
and so we're just going to say that it
does
here's the thing
there is a process if we decide or if
the government decides
if elected representatives decide who
allegedly are at the mercy of the people
if they decide that on behalf of the
people that a certain thing should be in
the Constitution though it isn't or a
certain thing which is in the
Constitution should not be there is a
process by which those things can be
added in
it's called amending and that is a
legislative process it is not a judicial
process the judiciary cannot look at the
Constitution and say well that should be
in there so let's so we'll just say that
it is they can't do that
that the legislative branch can do that
and so when the judicial branch acts
like the legislative branch that is
judicial activism so no matter how you
feel about abortion it is clear that roe
v wade is the number one prime example
of judicial activism
second thing putting putting road to the
side okay so that's row of your way
let's ask this question
is it bad is there something wrong with
a Christian fighting against abortion
fighting for its prohibition legally
because he the Christian feels called to
do so by his faith
I mean let's just you know according to
Tommy and and other leftist
we pro-lifers you know we're only
fighting for this because we're
Christian
well let's just say that's true in the
case of many for the case of many pro
lifers so
does that make us wrong does that make
us incorrect
and if it is if it does make us wrong if
it is bad if it is theocratic if it is
disqualifying well then guess what guess
what we've also disqualified the
abolition of slavery civil rights many
other things after all many of the great
human rights fights and victories in
American history have been motivated on
the part of many of the people fighting
for them by Christian convictions so I
asked you is that is the legitimacy of
slavery abolition now suddenly called
into question because most of the
abolitionists were devout Christians and
the only reason that they that they were
abolitionists is because they is because
of the fact of their of their religious
faith
what ket should we should we be should
we be scolding the Reverend Martin
Luther King jr. for pushing religion on
the country
because his conviction about civil
rights and equal rights was clearly
motivated by his Christian faith
and what about all the people if you
were to you know find a World War two
veteran and ask him why did you go
overseas and fight the Nazi scourge
I I guarantee you that a great many of
them would answer that at least part of
the reason was their faith a Christian
faith
so does that
does that call into question what they
did does that does that make world war
two into a holy war all of a sudden
America a theocracy because it has civil
rights just based on the fact that most
of the people fighting for civil rights
at the time were Christian
or do we recognize that though their
motivations in the case of the
abolitionists of the case of the people
fighting for civil rights and so on
though their motivations may have been
Christian their aim and the results of
their fight were humanitarian and
democratic
here's the third thing and this is the
real point
whatever whatever might be the personal
motivations of a pro-life a person does
it mean to be Christian to be pro-life
and the government doesn't need to be a
theocracy to outlaw the murder of the of
unborn humans
the claim that pro-lifers are making
again putting aside their personal
motivations and their personal beliefs
because that is 100% irrelevant the
claim that we make as pro-lifers we make
basically two claims and neither of them
have anything to do with Christian
theology
the first claim is a scientific claim we
claim that humans in the womb are human
because they can't be anything else
they they must be it is a human in the
womb is a living organism that is a
biological fact okay that no scientist
in the world disputes none not a single
one the human in the womb is a living
organism period and discussion that is a
scientific reality there is no way
around it
here's another reality if it's a living
organism it must belong to a species
destined all living organisms do
here's another fact if it's a living
organism conceived by two members of a
certain species then that living
organism must also be a member of that
same species so two kangaroos cannot
conceive a shark
two sharks can not conceive an ostrich
two human beings cannot conceive
anything but a human being so we have a
living organism who must be a human
being that is our scientific claim and
it is it's not even a claim it is a fact
that we are just asserting
here's the second claim that we make
that and this is a I admit this is a
moral claim so we have the scientific
claim and now we have the moral claim
look that claim is that a human in the
womb because he is human ought to be
treated just like every other human and
ought to have the same rights as every
other human so we make the exact same
moral claim that the abolitionists made
about slavery and you could now you
could disagree and you could say well no
it's not the same thing but the fact is
we are making the same moral claim it's
not a Christian theological claim it is
a it is a it is a moral claim and it has
to be moral because anytime you get into
ought to okay so I'm saying that a human
being ought to be treated as a human
being any time you use the word ought to
then you're talking about morality
so if you have any ideas whatsoever
about how a person ought to behave and
how we ought to act as a society and
what and how things ought to be then
those are moral beliefs that you have
they're not scientific beliefs
they are moral beliefs and in that way
every law our whole legal system is
based on a moral framework because the
law by definition tells people what they
should do and should not do and it even
punishes them for doing things they
shouldn't do
that is a moral process
does that mean that the law itself is
inherently Christian
does that mean that there were no laws
before Christianity came along
I mean honestly I'm flattered that the
way left is talk about Christianity they
they basically give us credit for I got
I don't know we Christian Christians we
invented law we invented human decency
dignity we invented morality I mean all
these are all ours and honestly I'd love
to take credit for all that but no
that's these are these are these are
broader and and and things that
pre-existed Christian theology
now it is true that the pro-life
position while not specifically
Christian is grounded inevitably in a
belief in a creator god that is true
so I admit that
but if that's what you mean by pushing
religion then fine but then the entire
doctrine of human rights is also
theocratic and should be abolished and
what is the doctrine of human arts and
the doctrine of human rights is in fact
a doctrine it is a dogma it is not it is
not a scientific observation human
rights are not things that can be
observed within the person if you look
within a person you're not going to find
oh yeah there's their right to free
speech right there
no again human rights those are those
are that is a spiritual doctrine and
what is the doctrine well Thomas
Jefferson helpfully outlined it for us
we hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that among
these are life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness
a human right cannot be unalienable it
cannot be inherent it cannot be
self-evident unless it is a part of our
very nature as humans and endowed by a
force above us above humanity a creative
force that's what that is the founding
document of the United States of America
and that is what it says right at the
top
that we are founding this country upon
this spiritual doctrine of human rights
that are endowed by a Creator God
that is literally the foundation of the
United States of America
and it has to be that way because if
rights are simply assigned by the
government or decided by the whims of
the mob or voted on by the people then
rights are not unalienable they are not
self-evident they are not inherent they
are not endowed supernaturally and
therefore the very foundations of our
country are void and the Bill of Rights
itself should be discarded
but then here's the problem so if we get
rid of human rights we get rid of the
Bill of Rights then the basis for the
right to book to abortion has also been
discarded
you can't disqualify the argument
against abortion without disqualifying
the argument for it
that's that's the that's the problem
that you have if you're pro-abortion
row v Wade
and pro-abortion people they claim that
there is a right to abortion
and I assume that they believe that it
is an unalienable right in fact I know
they believe in that because they would
say that if it's not unalienable if it's
a right that's just decided by the
people well then you couldn't complain
when the people decide to take the right
away but no you're saying it's an
unalienable right and if it's
unalienable then it's part of our human
nature and if it's part of our human
nature than it was endowed by God so
what you're saying is that God has given
you the right to kill your children
that is a spiritual argument that you
are making and it is a demented insane
spiritual argument
so the pro-life the pro-life case is not
Christian but it is spiritual
and the pro-abortion case is spiritual
too
and if you have a problem with all of
that and you don't like to admit that
these are spiritual arguments then at
least have the intellectual integrity to
admit that you have a problem with human
rights themselves which are also
spiritual in that they cannot be
observed they cannot be a product of
evolution
and if they are real at all they must be
inherent
and therefore objective
so forth thing
or maybe I'm on the third thing again I
get kind of carried away
last point I'll just put it up whoo so
as we've established the pro-life case
is a scientific case it's also a
spiritual case admittedly but it is a
spiritual case it in the same vein on
the in the same way that human rights
themselves are a spiritual case
but who was really making the religious
case
this specifically religious like you'd
have to be a part of this religion to
believe it
the pro-life case is grounded in
biological science and universal moral
law Universal because all people
everywhere agree that murder is wrong
that is a universal this is a also one
of the most compelling proofs for the
existence of God that there that there
exist this universal morality that
everywhere in the world everyone
everywhere in the world throughout
history has agreed with you take even
civilizations that never encountered
each other before and they came to the
same kind of conclusion now it's also
true that most civilizations many
including ours have tried to make
exceptions to this idea that it's wrong
to murder or they have come up with
forms of murder that they claim are not
murder
but they all still agree in the end that
murder is wrong what they try to do is
parse it and kind of compartmentalize
and so as to still allow the murder of
certain kinds of people
that's what the pro-life cases grounded
the pro-abortion case the other hand is
grounded in not science at all there's
no science to it it's pure dogma and
it's grounded in some kind of moral law
that is confused and incomprehensible
and just completely utterly baseless
the pro-abortion person believes two
things believes number one that the
biological status of a human person in
the womb hinges on the the desires and
feelings of its mother
this is what pro-abortion people say
this is not I'm not this is not a straw
man if you were to ask them when does
life begin what they'll tell you is well
it's it's up to the mother
so if the mother refers to her baby as a
baby then it's a baby if the mother
wants the baby then it's a person it's
living if the mother doesn't want the
person calls it a fetus then it's a
fetus and it's not a person
that's what pro-abortion people believe
that's what they'll tell you there is no
science whatsoever to back that up the
idea that the the biological status of a
person can be dependent upon the
preferences of another person I mean
that's just a superstition is that is
the definition of anti science so they
have an anti scientific view and their
moral view is not universal at all it's
it's very particular to their belief
system it is that's why I call it
religious or cultish if you want
you know pro-lifers say you shouldn't
murder okay everyone agrees and we might
disagree about how you apply it so on
but we all agree don't murk
what pro-abortion people say though is
is is is is different they believe that
it can be morally acceptable to kill a
defenseless and innocent human organism
but only on three conditions the first
condition is that this life is
inconvenient the second is that the life
is not yet born and in the third
condition is the most absurd the third
condition is that this that the person
killing the life or having the life
killed is the parent
of the life
so the person being kid
must be the biological child of the
person who is killing them
so traditional morality would find that
all murder is horrible but no form of
murder is more horrible than the murder
of a child by a parent that's
traditional morality most people in the
world would say that's the worst kind of
Murli it's it's all bad that's the
absolute worst kind that's the most said
abomination
but the pro-abortion version of morality
will say that all forms of murder are
wrong except for the murder of your own
child
again I can only call that a religious
belief it's not scientific
it's not Universal it's not self-evident
it's not grounded in any kind of natural
moral law
it's just that it is a
it is a doctrinal view
that is shared only by leftists it's a
part of their religion
so that's what we find
but while pro lifers are making a
scientific case
in a moral case it is actually the
pro-abortion people who are making a
specifically religious cultish case
they are the ones we're trying to
establish ate their own kind of
theocracy
they want laws that govern according to
their own specific particular moral
views
so that's why they don't want us to push
our religion on them it's because
they're trying to push their religion on
us
they don't like all the competition I
guess all right
thanks for listening Godspeed